tell me what you want what you really
really want is that that
self-explanatory no I'm not saying what
does that [__] mean I thought you
going to say zig ziga what does that
mean what I thought you going say what
does ziga zigar
mean now I will is that part of song
that's part of that part of the song oh
okay what does that mean well I'm not
going to tell you now because you didn't
even know it was part of that lyric okay
that you know what it means Zig no I
don't know what it means but I know that
Zig Zig
zig Zig Zig tell me what you want what
you really really want Zig Zig no I
really really really want a zigazig ah
oh is that fingering or is that nothing
it just I I just when I'm asking
questions I do I use my hands so what is
your that's terrible isn't it I know is
that sex was that sex zig
ziga for start it can be anything that
you want it to mean but for me did you
write that lyric yes okay so then what
the [__] does it
mean you know I know I don't want to
tell her guess what it means I have no
idea might be the weirdest never we've
done yet I like it I don't think it's
weird I don't no it's not we're learning
a lot and we're getting a lot very
similar to all the other ones you've
done this is just a this is an hour with
Mel but so Mel did you write that that
all of our songs we were listening to
rager we were listening to reggae and
rager and we're all like pumped up I
don't know what rer it's like Jamaican
dance hall regy ragas skanky like that
kind of stuff and we were all really rer
like uh
re re that was a really white boy thing
to say oh oh you listen to
Reg my dad L it's when when my gay
friends go to Jamaica and dance it's
regay so we were kind of amped up
because before we write songs we would
listen to kind of music that we wanted
to I don't know that got us like in that
zone so if we're going to write a ballad
we would listen to some B like slow
songs beforehand I get it and we wanted
an upbeat song for our like first single
so we're listening to a lot of Reggae a
lot of rager lot of bie banto and kind
of a bit of like ghetto like music and
you know they do a lot of that pwa
talk yeah in regga and that so how did
you come up tell me what you want with
did you write that lyric alone like did
you ever come up do you ever think of a
lyric in your head and you write it down
that's the only one that is made up the
rest we wrote Like lyrics and sentences
that make sense like to become one is
about safe sex if you sing it then it's
just about two people becoming one it's
safe sex yeah Two Become One the slow
ballad spy skills song No I know the
song but why is that safe sex because
you be a little bit wiser baby put it on
put it on cuz T is it to become on it's
about saying put a condom on before we
have sex what is the two becoming one
well because then you're one body aren't
you oh then you come together that's I'm
starting to learn so it's about doing
lyrics where you're getting a message
across still family friendly yeah I just
because can I explain something to you
go on I understand everything you're
saying I do this for the audience so
that they they understand it so they
follow along but ziga ziga does mean yes
I did write write that particular zig
ziga high this is what you
wrote zig ziga with all the songs Zig
Zig Zig Zig Zig no zig a zig I know I
know I have a Canadian accent yeah but
you putting too many words in there Zig
a it I see Canada yeah yeah I understand
it what I have to do is
hey
he